وفي كلمته امام مؤتمر دعم مستقبل سوريا
والمنطقه المنعقد في بروكسل قال مسؤول
السياسه الخارجيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي
جوزي بورن انه لا يمكن للاسره الدوليه ان
تتجاهل محنه اللاجئين السوريين ولا ينبغي
التسامح مع وجود مازق كبير كهذا واضاف
جامعه الدول العربيه اتخذت قرار اعاده
سوريا الى الجامعه وكان هناك عمل على
تطبيع العلاقات بين دول العربيه والنظام
السوري غير ان الاتحاد الاوروبي لم يكن
ليختار مثل هذا المسار وفق تعبيره
لا يمكن للاسره الدوليه ان تتجاهل محنه
اللاجئين السوريين ومن غير المقبول ان
التسامح مع وجود مازق كهذا يؤثر على
السوريين يجب علينا ان نعمل بايجابيه لنصل
الى حل هذا النزاع ومهمتنا اليوم على نحو
محدد يجب ان تكون مرتبطه بوجود امل
للتخفيف من وطاه معاناه السوريين جامعه
الدول العربيه اتخذت قرارا باعاده سوريا
الى الجامعه وكان هناك عمل على تطبيع
العلاقات بين دول عربيه والنظام في دمشق
هناك محاوله تركيه لحل بعض مشاكلها ضمن
السياق الخاص بالعلاقه مع النظام السوري
نقول لكم ان الاتحاد الاوروبي لم يكن
ليختار هذا المسار